Still upset over the prospect of never getting
to see Zack Snyder's version of Justice League?
Well, grab your tissues, because a newly released
image from Snyder's version of the superhero
film has teased a heartbreaking death that'll
be sure to get you welling up.
Taking to the social media platform Vero,
Snyder shared a still from a scene of his
cut of Justice League, which reveals a crucial
plot point in Cyborg's storyline.
The black-and-white shot shows Cyborg with
his hand pressed against a pane of glass,
looking on as his father, S.T.A.R.
Labs head Dr. Silas Stone, is apparently burnt
alive in what appears to be a containment
chamber.
It seems the fire may have been a result of
an explosion that involved a Mother Box, a
powerful piece of technology that appeared
in both Snyder's Justice League and the theatrical
version directed by Joss Whedon.
Snyder had planned to explore an alternate
history of the Mother Boxes, and has even
shared storyboard art that suggested his Justice
League would have seen Cyborg discussing the
Boxes' inception, and their connection to
the Nazis during World War II.
Snyder captioned the still from Silas' death
scene, "You would also cry" teasing the effect
his take on Justice League would have on audiences.
And watching a beloved hero witness the death
of his father from just a few feet away would
no doubt be devastating, so Snyder isn't wrong
there.
It's obvious that Snyder's vision for Justice
League was going to be far darker than Whedon's,
and including a death as emotional as the
one intended for Silas would have brought
the film to a somber place indeed.
But evidently that isn't what studio Warner
Bros. wanted out of Justice League particularly
because its predecessor, Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice, was slammed as a trainwreck
largely thanks to its gritty tone.
Rumors about Silas dying in Justice League
swirled around the production for months before
its November 2017 debut and have continued
to the present day, with many speculating
that his death would establish the foundation
for an eventual Cyborg solo film.
A pair of August 2018 tweets from The New
York Times' Kyle Buchanan, who cited a report
by Slashfilm, claimed that Silas did indeed
die in the original version of Justice League.
Buchanan wrote:
"Originally, Joe Morton's character was killed
halfway through, and Cyborg finds a video
from him at the end that lets Morton's lines
play over the final montage.
Whedon gave those lines to Amy Adams.
But Whedon's reshoots also nixed the Morton
death scene, so...a wash?"
In that Slashfilm report, Silas actor Joe
Morton confirmed that he filmed a ton of scenes
for Snyder's Justice League that were scrapped
when Whedon took over.
Morton maintained his hope that the sequences
removed from Justice League would be reworked
for the Cyborg standalone, and also told IGN
that part of the Justice League reshoots involved
adjusting Cyborg's tone to, quote, "lighten
up the film."
He explained:
"There was [more we shot].
They completely changed the story.
Unfortunately, I can't tell you what [the
original story] is because that might end
up being in part of the Cyborg movie.
Yes, there was a big change once they decided
that they were going to do the Cyborg film."
But whether the Cyborg movie ever ends up
happening, and whether the film will actually
include the Silas death scene Snyder teased,
is a mystery for right now.
According to Cyborg star Ray Fisher, the standalone
superhero flick, quote, "would be a very,
very costly movie to make because it is so
CGI heavy" which could explain why there hasn't
been much movement on it.
Unfortunately, rumors recently began to surface
suggesting that the Cyborg film is actually
dead in the water.
We Got This Covered cited unidentified sources
claiming Warner Bros. "just doesn't care about
making any more projects with Fisher."
Ouch.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.